Okay, welcome to lecture number five of
the course. Uh again in the fully online
mode today and let's uh start where we
stopped.
So what have we learned so far? So in
the last uh three lectures or roughly
three lectures what we've been doing is
we're trying to solve PDS rather than
learn them using deep neuronet networks.
And the main algorithm or the class of
algorithms that we're deploying are
physics informed neural networks or
pins. And I don't want to repeat what
pins are. I think by now you're very
familiar with what they are. But the key
points are when you are given a PTE,
you're going to approximate the solution
of that PT with neural networks. And to
do so since you don't have data about
the PD in the interior you just uh use
the neural networks or evaluate the PD
residual which is given by this
expression here uh at different
collocation points right so you take
some quadature points or collocation
points and evaluate the residual you
form this loss function and then you
minimize the loss function. So neural
network that approximates the local
minima the parameters of the neural
network that approximate the local
minima they are an approximation to your
solution of the PD. So it's a very
simple algorithm we also saw its success
in very various cases high dimensional
PDS parametric PDS inverse problems
where there there was a seamless
integration between physics and data. So
this is this is all done. What I did in
the last lecture is essentially show
this kind of an error estimate. Right?
So this error estimate was very very
crucial because it tells you the
behavior of the pin or the train pin
let's say and it says that the error
which is the mismatch between what the
pin gives us and the exact solution of
the PTE is given in in terms of several
components right one of them is this
component which uh relies on the number
of collocation points and as the number
of collocation points increases then
this part of the error goes down but the
overall thing depends on constants. This
is remember that this was due to the
coercivity or the stability of the BD.
Uh coercivity is a better expression
here.
So now what happens is that this guy can
be large right and we saw examples
particularly with problems with strong
gradients. So remember that we had this
example with burgers equation. We had
this example with Navi Stokes equation
where this gradient was strong and when
this gradient blows up or when this
gradient is large then the pin cannot
based on this estimate approximate the
solution of a PD. So this is something
that is a serious caveat right because
we know that the pin is not going to
work in that case but that's not enough
there is another source of a caveat. Let
me use another color and this is given
by the training error. Now all that we
know uh in advance is that this global
version of this training error the
training error can be made small
depending on your neural network
parameters depending on the size of your
problem and so on. But however to reach
the global minimum uh was a challenge
right because this is where I sort of uh
rushed through in the towards the end of
the last lecture because the math is uh
cumbersome. So the ultimate bottom line
was that uh training is necessarily an
illonditioned process and this is
fundamental. It has nothing to do with
neural networks per se. It is to do with
the fact that we are trying to impose or
trying to sort of minimize a least
squares norm on the residual. And this
implied that the number of iterations uh
in gradient descent for instance uh it's
scaled but it's scaled in terms of the
condition number not of d the
differential operator itself. Remember
that this is the differential operator
but in terms roughly of its square. This
is the hermission squared but in general
you can think of it as a square. So if d
is the lelassian
minus lelassian d star d was your
lelassian square. So essentially it told
us that if the number of it operator is
or if the problem is complicated you're
looking at higher modes then it's
inevitable that the number of steps will
be very very high. So this is what the
analysis tells us right and who can
fight math. So this is this is what is
also realized in practice. Uh I touched
up upon this in the last lecture. What I
said is that if you take solutions so
this is the PD it's just a twopoint
boundary value problem. It's lelassian
the poson equation but in uh one space
dimension right with zero boundary
conditions. So the solution is given by
u of x is equal to sin of kx
right then the boundary conditions also
automatically satisfied but remember
that k can be large or it could be a
combination of these things but let's
say it's sine of kx and even for this
simple problem we realized that uh
things didn't really work the condition
number as expected in this problem this
scales like a y quadratic as a fourth
power so if you have um k is equal to
100 then it this scales like 10 8 which
is I don't know how well you see it but
it is indeed 10 to the 8 so fits the
theory to a t and as a consequence for k
small you are able to reduce the loss
quite effectively with a finite number
of epochs but when k increases then this
really becomes very very bad and you
cannot uh of course it's not following a
linear pattern Because remember we made
approximations
but the bottom line is that this is a
very very bad uh badly behaved problem.
is such a simple problem that we can
solve you know just by looking at it
it's very clear what the solution is
going to be but because we have used
this particular sort of formulation of
the problem you see that this is uh this
is going to be very very difficult and
it doesn't help uh so yeah I will tell
you what preconditioning is but
essentially if you take an MLP then
after many many many iterations the loss
does not go down that much right it's
stuck somewhere Yeah. So even for this
simple problem, you don't really have a
solution and this was at K 10 or K20 or
something some moderate value of K. Uh
this is another example which is quite
striking. So this is just the adction
equation uh UT + beta * ux equals to 0.
And I think all of you probably should
know the solution. U of XT is the
initial condition translated out beta T.
Right? So this is the this is the
initial condition when you differentiate
you see that these two things match up
right. So now beta is the variable here
where the stiffness of the problem is
determined by beta and the condition
number is remember or not of the
operator itself but of the square. So
the condition number of d star d in this
case behaves like beta square. So as
beta increases this problem becomes
harder and harder and this is what you
find here. So this is how the condition
number grows. Uh this is quite quite a
high value for very very moderate
values. So beta beta equal to 30 and you
see this also in the loss curves. So
when beta is small uh in this regime you
are able to train it very very well. But
as soon as beta becomes beyond a certain
value the loss doesn't really converge.
it goes to it saturates uh at a very
high value. This is essentially order of
one
and you see that uh sort of pictorially.
So let's focus on on these two for the
time being.
Okay. The others are because I took it
from paper there is uh uh there are some
other things here. So the first thing is
that you take the exact solution. So
this is beta equal to 30 pi. So this is
uh t and this is a behavior in space. So
the domain is from 0 to 2 pi. Right? So
as you can see there is a
the wave moves in moves out moves in
moves out. There is periodic boundary
condition. This is how the solution
should look like. And when I use a pin
with a MLP and don't use any
preconditioning I'll come to
preconditioning in a second. Then in the
beginning you see that the solution is
fairly well captured but very very
quickly what happens is that uh you you
don't have any any sort of approximation
of the solution whatsoever. The problem
becomes hard. 30 pi is a high number. So
even if the solution itself this is a
very very simple problem you know in in
some sense and you see very clearly that
pins completely fail on these simple
problems and these things were
empirically identified a few years ago
but the theory was provided in the paper
that I that I just suggested.
uh yeah so you see the behavior again
this is um
the error so this is the loss and this
is the error and I have taken two
different values of beta beta equals to
10 and 30 and with the th00and epochs
with 10 the error uh yeah 10 30 doesn't
really matter the error is quite high of
course when you precondition this is
what I'm going to tell you in a second
then things improve for these simple
problems okay so even for the simplest
possible PDS. This is just
one-dimensional uh in space uh just
spatial. There's no temporal variation
and this problem here is uh
one-dimensional in space and time. You
see that even for the simplest problems
as long as you make the problem stiff.
Okay, stiff means that you you introduce
let's say smaller scales. You introduce
more complicated dynamics. For instance,
by increasing the number of modes that
are there, the wave number of the modes
or by increasing the infection velocity,
you end up um having problems with pins.
Okay. So this tells us that um this as
as it is does not work simply because
the training error if you go back uh
here the training error this is order of
one in general if the problem is
difficult this guy can be bad right it's
uh this this can be order of thousand
but if the training error is not able to
compensate for that then anyway we are
we are we are in some difficulty so what
what can we do in that case so the
operator is well ill condition. So when
an operator is ill or a matrix is ill
conditioned then you have to do
something called preconditioning and
many of the cases you saw the expression
preconditioning. Let me just uh very
very quickly I don't have the time or
the scope really to introduce what
preconditioning is but for those who
have done any kind of numerical methods
they would know what preconditioning is.
So if you have a matrix equation, let's
start with the simplest.
You take a matrix equation ax= to b and
let's say that the condition number of a
is high.
Then it is difficult to invert this
matrix. So that's the basic basic idea.
You cannot invert the matrix. So what
you do is that you premultiply
P another matrix and you say take P of A
X equals to P of B. Okay. And the idea
is that this P of A should be very close
to the identity because the condition
number the identity is one. That's the
best that we can do. The maximum value
the minimum value are exactly the same.
Right? So when you do preconditioning
the idea is that you change the problem
in such a manner that this becomes
easier to uh so it's P is an approximate
inverse
approximate inverse
okay and then uh what you can do is then
the problem becomes well conditioned
so well condition and this P is often
called as a preconditioner
And for numerical methods uh
particularly finite element methods and
so on preconditioning is a very very
important step
it is well established it has been done
for 50 60 years and so on but for pins
uh what is the how do we do this right
what is the there what is the
appropriate analog uh as it were so
there are many things that can be done
but roughly and I don't have the time to
sort of because this is still very much
a very very sort of emerging ing field
right it's uh essentially in the last
one or two years that people are looking
at preconditioners. So what you do is
that again remember that uh my
simplified gradient descent was
something like okay my gradient descent
was given by theta k + 1 equals to theta
k minus eta * the gradient of with
respect to theta of l of theta k
something like that that's my gradient
descent so what you do in this case is
that you do exactly the same you
multiply with some p perhaps p here p
here such that this guy here this
gradient term because remember that this
is where a matrix uh comes in this is
close to the identity so this is roughly
the idea okay mean it's it's it's it's
quite quite a bit of hand waving but
this is roughly the idea and uh there
are there are different ways to
interpret preconditioning but you can
roughly think of a change of variables
change of variables
in parameter space.
So parameters are theta and this
automatically implies uh preconditioning
not automatically but under the right
conditions preconditioning and function
space remember that we are dealing with
operators here. So this is your d star d
and what we need is an approximate
inverse of this and this is not the
easiest right but that's the roughly the
idea
and this will be there are many
approaches there are many many different
ways of doing it uh I don't give any
particular details okay so this was I
just gave the okay let's let's look at
different kinds of preconditioning
techniques so there are different uh
guises here and uh some of of them are
mentioned. So the main thing that you
can do is you can impose boundary
conditions in a hard manner. This was
already in the original proposal of pins
so that the boundary conditions don't
lead to any preconditioning but still it
does not take out the problems that come
from the operator itself. For time
dependent problems there is something
called causal learning which says that
uh you first solve for the initial time
steps then use those parameters solve
for the next time steps. use those
parameters, solve for the next time
steps and so on. Uh this is another way
of thinking about preconditioning. But
arguably the most successful is to use
what are called second order optimizers.
So things like Newton's method or
variations of Newton's method
Newton's method for and this is uh
effective this is pursued mostly by
Marius Zinhoer who is at ETH. She's a
postto of mine and Marius and his
collaborators they have sort of pushed
for this. The difficulty of course is
that uh these are expensive. So this is
not that not that easy. There are some
other things multi-stage neural networks
also from us. There are some domain
decomposition methods. They're different
different ways, right? So teaching all
of this is sort of pointless because
this is the the field itself is in a
state of flux. But at least for simple
problems. So the bottom line is for
simple problems whatever simple means
linear let's say and perhaps one or 2D
uh this is possible preconditioning is
possible and in fact uh so much so that
for instance this one is an example.
Yeah. So you see that this is beta equal
to 30. So without preconditioning it you
simply couldn't approximate the solution
except in the very beginning. But now
with the preconditioning because uh in
this case it's linear everything sort of
stacks up and if you precondition the
gradient you get uh pretty good results
and you also see that in the in the in
the curves here as I showed you that
without preconditioning the error was
stuck with preconditioning you're able
to push it down you're not able to
completely solve it but you are able to
push it down but this is a very very
simple problem right I'm not going to
use a pin to solve this problem but this
tells you that at least For simple
problems, there is a way out. And if you
learn how to scale it for more
complicated problems, perhaps in the
near future, we will be able to do
something. But the bottom line
unfortunately is that at the moment pins
are very narrow in their scope, right?
So they they they work in some sense for
easy problems. The equation might be
hard, but as long as the problem is
easy, you don't have high modes, you
don't have stiff dynamics, you can you
can use them. So here is an example.
Remember this is radiative transfer and
I was very sort of impressed or tried to
impress you with the fact that even if
you take a sixdimensional problem it
took about an hour and if I use fem uh
finite element method this would be 1
day. So this was a huge saving right? So
this was this is massive in 1D on the
other hand it still took an hour and in
this case the fem would take about a
minute
or less you see. So of course the fem is
going to grow exponentially with respect
to dimensions. This guy doesn't grow
exponentially with respect to dimensions
because neural networks are sort of they
they can they can prevent the curse of
dimensionality in some way. But this is
a fairly simple problem. But then the
point is that in in multi-d this was a
simpler problem. You see that the
solution is smoother. In 1D this was
more complicated. You have
discontinuities. It approximated it but
it took a long time to train. Right? So
this is long training time.
So in 1D it's useless in this particular
case. In multid it was useful because
the finite element method takes takes
forever. Similarly for the burgers
equation if you remember at least for
low values of the not zero but uh
non-zero values of the viscosity it
worked quite well but what is the cost
right so the caveat was in the cost that
it took even the most well-trained pins
take about 5 minutes
okay it takes time to train these
networks it takes many many steps of
gradient descent to be able to solve
this nonlinear problem very simple
nonlinear problem it does not have uh
the complexities that other problems
have. And if I would have just used the
simplest finite difference code in
Python, one, it takes about one/10enth
of a second. No optimization, nothing.
Maybe it takes a second if you're really
really naive about it. Right? So now
you're trying to solve a problem which
takes about 110th of a second and you
solve it in 5 minutes. It's in 1D. Okay,
you can solve. This is from the original
PIN paper. At the time, no one asked
this question. But now when the methods
are more mature, it's sort of inevitable
that these questions are asked, right?
So you you you cannot you cannot fool
around with this. It takes it takes a
long time to relatively long time for
this to converge and a more drastic
example. So this is one of the harder
problems that can be solved with pins
not very effectively. If you remember
that when the solution when the vortex
became more concentrated, this got
smoothened out. But again the time that
it took to solve this is approximately
an hour. It's a 2D problem. It's harder
in some cells it takes about an hour.
But with my spectral methods this takes
a second. Okay. So this is this is you
know this is the issue each time. There
are many many papers that are written
about pins. But if you ask questions
like this means do the same thing with
your traditional finite difference
solver or finite element solver for
simple one and 2D problems. uh this is
much much faster to do it with them
rather than use a pin right why why use
a neural network when you can get get
away with a very standard method a
neural network would make sense for
instance for the sixdimensional problem
or for a complicated three-dimensional
problem but in that case it doesn't work
because of the training training ill
conditioning right so in a way uh I'm
more or less coming to an end of the
section on pins the fact is that they
are an alternative to tradition
traditional PD solvers but they work
well potentially for hard problems but
with easy solutions by easy solutions I
mean sort of uh single scale perhaps
non-step
as long as the condition number is not
badly behaved but as soon as the
solution becomes more complicated even
for the simplest cases it becomes the
training becomes ill conditioning ill
condition and there are ways to sort of
get around that, amilarate it. But at
the moment, uh these are still in their
infancy and nothing really nothing
really scales uh to the extent that we
want to. So in a way despite the early
promise uh one can say that there is uh
there is an impass you know the things
are stuck you you cannot sort of improve
them. So the question that arises is
what is the alternative and this is what
we are going to look at in the next
several lectures. uh half the course uh
essentially. Okay. So at this point uh
since we are more or less finishing on
pins I would like to ask and if you guys
have any questions means either you can
unmute yourself or you can ask in the
chat and I would be happy to answer
means uh this goes without saying are
there any questions did uh you know I
don't expect you to follow every single
aspect of uh preconditioning or
illonditioning because the math is a bit
hard there but at least to understand
that the the the issue is that of
training error that's the or to to bring
the loss down because the problem the
optimization problem in some sense is
ill condition that's essentially the
bottom line but uh are there any
questions
no so in that case uh the question is
what's the alternative right so as you
could have imagined uh the point about
pins is yeah there was a question from
Giovani for parabolic equations would it
make sense uh to take the associated
functional as the training loss. Uh
Giovanni, do you mean that uh you are
taking the weak form of the equation? Is
that what you want or what is the
associated functional?
>> Yes, I mean the weak form.
>> You mean the weak form? Okay. So this is
a question that Giovanni asked. Maybe I
should uh sort of take the time to
explain a little bit. So remember that.
Um
yeah. So let's take that uh let's start
with minus llassian of u equal to f and
you could uh could argue that there is a
there is a variational formulation
this is a strong form of the bd there is
a variational formulation
which provides you with a weak form
and that is given by two things you can
either use a energy functional energy
So this is given by half the integral
over the domain of the gradient of u ^2
minus u f dx. Okay. So this is the
energy function. So you have an energy
and what you can do is you can uh say
that minimum
theta belongs to
some theta of j of u theta. So and uh u
u thetas are neural networks.
So this is a method. This is uh analog
of pins. So instead of using the strong
form of the equation, you're using the
weak form of the equation. You are
trying to minimize uh this. It's called
deep ritz method. Sometimes
deep ritz the answer to that is
unfortunately it's exactly the same
problem. So when you try to do the do
this with respect to neuronet networks,
the conditioning of the training process
is still very very bad. Okay, it does
not really help if you if you do this
because you're again sort of using le
squares, right? And it's sort of maybe
for this particular problem it's easier
to precondition but in general the
answer is no. Okay, so you can you can
do that. You can also use another form
which is given by what is called a
variational form. So this could be given
by using test functions. Let's say this
is gradient of u dot gradient of theta
minus u of f dx oh sorry theta of f not
theta v f gradient of v f of f dx so
this is another form which is b of
no I shouldn't use okay I can use b of u
v so this is also the weak form this is
the oiler branch equation corresponding
to this uh problem this optimization
problem and you can in principle set um
equals to okay uh you can take some
square of this. This does not really
help because uh you also have to take
either neural networks or basis
functions. So none of these sort of
workarounds help because essentially you
are trying to solve an optimization
problem the wrong way you know because
if you did this with a with a
traditional finite element you will have
a not an underdetermined but a pre or an
exact determined problem. you have the
same number of unknowns as variables but
uh as equations let's say but you know
with uh with neuronet networks you
somehow need to overparameterize them
and this is where problems crop up so
good question and perhaps worth uh and
there are different names some some
people call it as variational pins v
pins but they have exactly the same
problems as pins have they're not a
they're not a solution except in some
simple cases
Okay. So what do we do? Uh we didn't
really use data you know because uh we
said okay data is uh we don't need data
because in a traditional numerical
method we didn't need data. So we just
replaced find relevant basis functions
or find volume basis functions with new
networks. But we didn't use data. And
this is still a degree of freedom that
we have. Can we use data? And in fact in
the next several lectures what we are
going to do is we are going to use uh
some supervised learning. Okay
supervised learning uh supervised
learning is when you try to match the
data for PDS and this is going to be our
our main goal. Uh perhaps let me start a
little and then we see how far we go
with this. Right. So what does it mean
to use data? Right. So pins had a
particular flavor to them that they were
essentially given x and t. You were
determining u theta of xt which
approximated u of xt
right so this was somehow the setting
that we had but it turns out that if you
think about pds uh there are different
ways to interpret what does it mean to
solve a pd. So this is the question that
I'm asking what does it mean to solve a
pd.
So let us take some examples and try to
work this out. So first let's consider a
very standard PD. This is the PD that
you saw before. If A is identity A is
identity matrix. This is nothing but
minus lelassian of U= to F. So this is a
posype PD. It's sometimes called DC uh
PD but that's just one name and
different kinds of physics is going to
be modeled by it. Right? So one
particular example would be uh on
subsurface flow. This is where this Darc
the the name Darc comes from. So what
does subsurface flow do? So the your um
this is your subsurface. This is what is
called the permeability. So this is the
permeability
and then you are digging right? So you
put some load you F here is the load or
the source and then you extract the
fluid. So you have some fluid trapped in
rocks under the ground. you extra put in
some pressure and because of the
pressure difference uh
you think the fluid comes out right so
the pressure distribution then is given
by this uh this color bar color map here
so this is an example another example
that you could think of it is heat
conduction steady state heat conduction
so material you heat it and you want to
see how the temperature is distributed
so this a here will be your conductivity
so conductance or conductivity
uh and then um u is going to be the
temperature distribution. That's another
example of this process. It could also
be a voltage. So you apply a current,
you want to see how the voltage changes
and this is going to be your
conductivity or the inverse of
resistivity. So many many different
problems dealing with diffusion effects,
right? Things spread. So diffusion is
nothing but spreading or directed
spreading uh things spread. This is
modeled by this equation, right? And
what does it mean to solve this PD? So
you can do different things here. So one
thing that we can do is we fix the
source fix. We can vary it but just for
notational simplicity we are going to
fix f right. Then the objective is to
given the input. So you can think of the
PTE as sort of representing a system. So
in engineering you know we deal with
systems and we have inputs to the system
and the outputs to the system are the
response to the system in in the
presence of these inputs. Uh if you take
the same sort of thinking line of
thinking then what happens is that uh
the input to the PD here is given by my
permitivity or my uh conductivity or
whatever a and the output is given by u.
So if I vary a I need a different
output. If I have v a I need a different
output and so on. And this relationship
between inputs and outputs is given by
what is called a solution operator. So
what is a solution operator? It's a
mapping. It's a mapping which takes the
input uh to the PTE which in this case
is just the conductivity.
This doesn't look good. And then it
transfers it to the output. Okay. So
that's what is an operator. It's a
mapping. It's it's a mapping. So it
takes a transformation and it moves
things from the input space to the
output space. Why is it an operator?
It's an operator because this is
essentially an infinite dimensional
description of the problem. Right?
Because its input a is given by
functions. So these are you know you can
in principle you can describe the
permeability or the conductivity. If you
take a material you can measure the
conductivity at any point right. So this
is the the principle. So this is going
to be a function.
In this case it is a positive function.
It's non- negative because conductivity
or permeability cannot be negative and
it is uh it's a bounded function. It's
it has some nice properties. Okay. It's
essentially a bounded positive function.
And this guy on the other hand the
solution of the PD it is also a
function. You can measure the pressure
the temperature at any point in
principle and it belongs to some sober
space. But this is this is a detail but
the essential point is that the operator
once we know the operator essentially we
can solve the PD on the fly right
because then given a new uh input we can
find a new output it's very very
different from the previous thinking the
previous thinking was you fix a you fix
f and that at different points in space
you tell what is the reading of uh u but
that's a that's a sort of a not naive
perhaps but that's a first order
thinking this is more of a second order
thinking that you think of the PT as a
system and given an input you provide an
output okay input is a function output
is also going to be a function uh let me
give you another example so so we work
out different cases so this is a time
dependent PD this is an example it's
given by the compressible oiler
equations uh into D so the the input now
to the PD so we have some boundary
conditions
boundary conditions uh let's think of
them as periodic. In the previous case,
it was zero directly boundary
conditions. So the values of the
boundary were sorry the values of the
boundary were zero.
So what are the how what is the systemic
thinking here? The systemic thinking
here is that the unknowns or the
variables are given by the density, the
velocity field and the total energy or
the pressure for for that matter
temperature whatever you want to think
of. And then the system what it does is
that it takes an initial condition
because the boundary conditions are
fixed. There are no coefficients here.
Initial condition and transforms it to
solution at a later time. So u dot t.
All right. So it's solution at later
time. It could be um a series of time
steps or the whole time history. Uh it's
what is called a trajectory. But
nevertheless the thinking is the same.
So the input is given by a function. the
initial condition you can measure the
density or the temperature or the
pressure at any point and you look at
this uh solution output later at any
given time again you can measure at any
point. So it takes an input a given by
okay a is the initial condition not u
and then it takes it to a later time. So
again this is a function to a function
mapping so hence an operator. So
essentially in this uh interpretation of
PDS and this is a widely used
interpretation PDS measure or represent
systemic behavior and they're
encapsulated the the behavior is
encapsulated by these uh solution
operators or operators which map
functions to functions. Okay. So is this
clear? So this will be the perspective
that we are going to take and it's very
very different from the perspective that
you took with respect to pins because in
pins I would just give you a x a point
and a time uh t time and then you
compute the solution u of xt but for the
fixed initial condition so for each
initial condition you're going to
measure this right but remember that
with respect to data then we we didn't
have data for these kind of settings but
now by taking the systemic uh sort of
oper operator formalism. What we are
saying is that we are not solving for
one fixed initial condition but we're
solving for a whole family of initial
conditions and this is a completely
different perspective and it's a much
richer perspective because it sort of
measures system behavior. So let me just
summarize. So this learning of these
operators forward and inverse operators
as you will see in the course is what is
sometimes called as operator learning.
Let me use something.
Okay, what is operator learning? So what
did we see? We saw from a PTE
perspective that the solution. So think
of this as a solution operator.
But as you'll see later, it's need not
only be the solution operator. Okay, it
could be something far richer but uh or
different like the inverse operator for
instance. So what does a solution
operator do? It takes a function input
and it maps it to a function output.
They could be different function spaces.
They could be the same function space.
But the key is that these are functions.
And a function is essentially an
infinite dimensional object. You cannot
characterize it by one number, right? Or
a set of numbers. It's it's really a
continum description. And this is the
key point that the dimension is going to
be infinity. And what we want to do is
to learn these operators from data.
Okay. So learn these operators from
data. Which means that I need to put in
some description of the data. Where does
this data come from? Uh this we will of
course expand in due course but often
the the most abstract or perhaps the
most general setting is that you put in
a probability measure on the function
space. Uh this can be done. You know
putting a probability measure on the
function space is very similar to having
a probability measure on a vector space.
No problems with that. And this mu here
is what is your data distribution. So
you're assuming that you are able to
draw from this data. The samples that
you see comes from this data. So then
what happens? So for each of these
samples is called AI. It's an input to a
PD. Think of it as the initial
conditions
or as the coefficients the permeability
for instance in a Darc type problem
right. So then we have the initial
conditions and what we can do is that
for each of them we have the
so given a AI I have my G this operator.
So this gives me G of AI which is UI. G
of AI it's a nonlinear map you know it's
not a linear map it's a nonlinear map
and this is my data pairs. So this AI
UI are my data pairs
and I assume that I have access to n of
them. N could be 10. N could be a
thousand. n could be tens of thousands
or if you have like the weather data n
is a very very large number 100,000 of
the order of 100 thousand but the point
is that uh and also in this course we
will see something of that order order
of 100,000 to a million but uh the point
is that each of this is assumed to be
drawn from this distribution so in
mathematical terminology in terms of
notation you have what is called a push
forward okay so this is your operator
learning task that we are trying to
measure or we're trying to predict.
We're trying to find out the
distribution. So you have some given
distribution. This is your mu. Then you
have your mapping g. And that takes you
to another distribution which is your g
push forward of mu. And you want to
learn this one learn.
And I'm assuming that there is no noise
uh in the output. But you can also
assume that uh so this is a simpl
simplification noiseless output in
practice of course this is not
necessarily the case but you can always
have some noise also you can say that
your UI is nothing but g of ai plus some
i and i is some normal distributed noise
and as long as the ti is going to be
small uh this is also a well- definfined
problem so sometimes we are going to
have noise but for mathematical as well
as uh implementational simplicity we'll
be in a noise-free case. So now for the
next five six lectures even our
objective or four five lectures our
objective would be to focus on this
operator learning task. Can we learn the
solution operator of a PTE um or the
inverse operator of a PTE given data and
the setting is this it's infinite
dimensional because functions are
necessarily infinite dimensional and uh
there are distributions so the data is
drawn from a distribution and then
whether we can we can solve this problem
right so this is a appropriate place to
take a break I will repeat what the
operator learning task is after the
break and we'll see how to address it
okay so my suggestion is that uh since
we are on Zoom, let's take a longish
break uh and we gather at quarter and if
you have any questions in the meanwhile
please don't hesitate to put it on the
on the chat. So talk to you in 15
minutes.
So welcome back. Let's uh start where we
stopped which is to repeat what operator
learning is all about. So essentially
what I said before the before the break
is that now the solution operator has
function inputs and outputs and we can
sort of define a data distribution on
the inputs and on the outputs if
necessary with noise but in general for
the for simplicity we'll only deal with
inputs and then we are going to learn
this operator from the from this data
pairs okay so the setting is very very
similar to traditional machine learning
which I taught in the second lecture But
with the difference now that your inputs
and outputs are infinite dimensional and
this is sort of best measured by the
fact that uh so of course we are going
to learn using new networks right but
here it's worth repeating that uh neural
networks are maps which take vector
inputs and provide vector outputs right
whereas with operator learning the sort
of the key difference is that the inputs
and the outputs are in principle
functions so you cannot directly use
neural networks as it is to do operator
learning. You have to do some either the
deduction from infinite to finite
dimensions and then use neural networks
or you can do an extension from finite
to infinite dimensions and then use the
data that we have been given. So this is
a setting that we're in that uh we have
uh posed this problem. We have
formulated this problem in terms of
operators in terms of learning operators
but doing that using just neuronet
networks is uh is at least a priority
not that simple right so but we we are
going to do that you'll see there are
different different steps that we're
going to take in this direction. Okay.
So, are there any questions about this
basic uh perspective or this basic
formalism of operator learning? Means
you had time to think over the break. If
you have any questions, you can either
ask now or you can also write in the
chat uh about just understanding
operator learning because it's very very
important. Uh of course we will do many
many examples so it'll get clarified uh
in the future but it's important to uh
tell me if there are some questions that
you have. If not, let me just uh give
you some potential solutions, right? So,
how do we go from an essentially
infinite dimensional problem, which is
what operator learning is, and use
essentially finite dimensional um
processes or finite dimensional
constructions to do that, which are
neural networks. So, one way is uh sort
of a cheating is uh to use parametric
PDs, right? I had already introduced
parametric PDs. So what is and this is
sort of uh many people think that this
is this is enough that you can do things
using parametric PDEs but we will see
that that is far from the case. So let
me try to explain what it is. So if you
remember that my solution operator it
takes a function space panak space as it
were and it maps it into another
function space another banak space and
this is your uh input output ratio or
the input output relationship not the
ratio and now what I've done is I've
changed my PD slightly it's the same PD
you can think of minus type uh what what
has happened
Sorry
there was some issue with my screen. So
you can think of this uh DC c uh type
problem which is minus divergence of a
gradient of u equals f right. So this is
the pd that we are interested in
solving. So now think of this solution
operator as not just taking a but also
taking a and f. So this is um one tupole
that is put into the problem and the
solution that you get out of it is uh u.
So this is your solution operator. It's
it's a it's a well- definfined problem
in that sense. Now the idea is that in a
simplified setting and this uh mu is
your uh initial probability measure
right which takes into account it's a
probability measure on the inputs and in
this very simplified setting you say
okay mu is uh in principle an infinite
dimensional function infinite
dimensional distribution but what if uh
the support of mu the the definition of
mu is defined in terms of finitely many
parameters and I'll give you many many
many different concrete examples of them
not many but a couple to sort of uh
explain that. So you end up instead of
having uh PTE sort of a infinite
dimensional formulation end up having a
parameterized PD with a finite number of
parameters. So let me try to explain it
in two cases and then you'll see what
what I mean here. So the first example
uh is uh this let's let's start with
this one here. So this is uh your
traditional example that I started out
with which is that you you you change
the shape of the air foil. So change the
shape of the air foil and then the flow
around the air foil changes. So this is
your input a and this is your output u.
Right? So a is the shape shape function
and u is your um whatever velocity field
for instance
I think this what I'm showing here is
the mark number but uh just imagine that
this is the velocity field okay so now
what happens is that this shape
functions a in general these are
functions right this for instance could
be the level set of the shape that that
we are having or a characteristic
function of the shape that we are
But in principle this can be
parameterized by a few parameters. Okay.
So instead of having looking at all
possible functions you can say that my a
is given by some ai
uh of fi of a of x is equal to a i fi of
x. fi are some basis functions
basis functions
and i from 1 to capital k. So we have k
basis functions and this is now so the
basis functions are fixed. I never
change my basis functions. All that I
change are these coefficients here. So
essentially now instead of having a
mapping from a to f a to u what you have
is a mapping of these vectors i to k to
u and it may not be u because you can
also say that who cares about the whole
flow field. All that I care about is one
quantity of interest or two quantities
of interest. And for air foils or flows
uh past objects this is going to be the
lift and the drag.
So essentially this is an infinite
dimensional problem. Maybe it's worth
explaining it in a separate sheet. So
what I have is uh sort of the operator
is mapping g which takes a to u. So this
is the shape to flow right velocity for
instance could be density it could be
other variables but let's say something
uh velocity density pressure and so on
density pressure
but I can reformulate it in terms of
parameters parametric formulation
and what is a parametric formulation so
what you do is that your a you write it
as a f_subi of X I from 1 to K
and uh the output is given in terms of
functionals.
So what are these functionals? This
could be drag uh lift
let's say dy dl and d um or
dl and dd and this is given by some
integrals of u of u x some sid of x for
instance dx so these are some sort of
integrals surface integrals in general
but uh this is some sort of integrals so
instead of having this mapping What we
have is a much simpler mapping which is
from parameters
to observables
and now I don't call it as G I call it
as G hat perhaps. So this takes AI this
parameters and it goes to the
observables which is DL and DD.
So instead of dealing with an infinite
dimensional problem out here which was
uh fairly complicated problem all that
you do is that you deal with a fairly
simple problem which is taking I don't
know in this case 20 parameters and
reading out two numbers right so
essentially the operator part of it is
completely subsumed there are issues
with this as you will see but you you
can agree with me that uh by writing the
problem like this I have essentially
reduced an infinite dimensional problem
a very difficult problem to a very
simple problem and this can be readily
solved you know because then it's just a
mapping between uh 20 vectors to two
vectors for instance uh this is a this a
fairly simple mapping and this can be
solved uh I think there is a solution in
this very page so these are the
parameters so you can predict the drag
and the lift you can also predict the
flow field at a set of set of points and
as you can see this this works very well
the lift is predicted to less than 1%
the drag is predicted to 1.9% 2% and the
whole field is also predicted uh in this
particular case. So you have at a at a
fixed number of points. Okay. So you
have this is your exact solution. This
is what the neural network predicts. So
this works well. Uh so in many many
problems the infinite dimensionality can
be subsumed within a very small set of
parameters. But uh as you might imagine
this is uh otherwise I wouldn't be
saying that I need five lectures, right?
I could just do it in 5 minutes. if this
was all that I have to do but it turns
out that there are some serious issues
with this this kind of okay there's a
question from Oliver what are typical
candidates for the basis functions that
you this is problem dependent so for
this uh particular problem the the
parameters are given by some hicks henna
this is a classic parameterization from
aerodynamics hicks and henn were
aerodynamicists at the royal aircraft
establishment many many years ago and
these essentially spline functions
but in some other cases it could be
other kinds of basis functions um values
will blush in for instance or 4 year
basis it depends on the problem that
that you're looking at and in fact this
is precisely the first caveat right mean
whatever Olivia just Oliver just asked
which is that it's uh there are many
challenges with parameterization and the
biggest one is that it's difficult to
come up with a suitable one you don't
necessarily know what is what is a
suitable one and whatever you do this is
not going to be unique at all right
because different parameterizations can
lead to the same output here's an
example so the the the parametric
function going from a vector going from
a scala 01 to the square can also be
exactly the same a1 b1 and a2 b2 have to
be determined but this is exactly the
same as this more complex
parameterization So the point that I'm
trying to make is that it will never be
first of all it may not exist even if
it's existing it is some sometimes
difficult to parameterize
it requires a lot of expert knowledge
without this expert knowledge it's very
difficult to construct
suitable parameterizations right so and
even if it exists it's not going to be
unique
see often these par parametric
descriptions are because us as humans we
can only interpret a few things right so
for instance for air foils these are
typically
you know different uh maybe maybe I if
you're interested I can even send you
some parameterizations these are
different sort of bumps these are
different bump functions so these are
different bumps on the on the surface of
the air foil to make it more rounded or
to make it maybe there is a description
here is better yeah so as you can
imagine so this is your base air foil
And then by these 20 parameters or so we
can sort of adjust it within this design
envelope. So we as humans we we sort of
interpret finitely many parameters much
better than some infinite dimensional
description. So often the input is
easier to write in terms of parameters.
The output is much harder to write in
terms of parameters because we have no
control on the output of the system.
Right? So nevertheless the point is it's
difficult to find a unique
parameterization. But even if it did,
even if it did, the biggest challenge is
and this is an important point about
machine learning is that it's all about
generalization, right? It's all about
the ability to make predictions uh when
which have not been seen during
training. That is the that is sort of
the main challenge. And this is exactly
what happens in this particular problem
here.
So remember that I have this air foil. I
have this spline functions and by
adjusting the coefficient of these
spline functions I get different kinds
of shape. Now let's imagine that I have
20 parameters that I'm adjusting and I
have trained my neural network on these
20 parameters. So what does my neural
network do? It takes a vector. It takes
essentially R20 and it goes let's say to
R2. It just predicts the drag on the
left. It could also predict the whole
flow field but let's let's just focus on
the drag on the left right and then
almost inevitably what happens is that
there is a limit to it because then
suddenly some other person in the same
or the same person who is designing this
parameterization he says no no I need a
little bit more variety in my air foils
it's not enough uh just to describe
these kind of shapes I need a little bit
more angular shapes maybe my drag is
going to be less my lift is going to be
more and then this is not possible
within 20 parameters is and this is an
example where the number of shape
functions or basis functions was
adjusted to 30 and you get a different
flow air foil. You of course get a very
different flow field because earlier the
shock which is key here was attached
much later. Now the shock is attached
much before but this is a qualitative
variation. There could be some design
choices that you make but the point is
now you have trained a neural network.
It goes from 20 dimensions to two
dimensions and suddenly you are
confronted with an input which is 30
dimensions. What do you do? Why
non-uniqueness is a problem? So Anna
asks why non-uniqueness is a problem?
Because you have to fix the par
parameters Anna, right? So you let's say
that you have two parameters uh to
describe the system. You defined your
neural network and then you change the
description completely. It's not going
to work, right? because it has only
understood that this is a function from
these two parameters or these 20
parameters to these two parameters. If
you change to a different set of
parameters, it is not going to work at
all. Maybe we can give an easy exercise
just to highlight that. But do you see
the the main main issue here is now my
neural network is going to be useless.
Even though the shapes don't look very
different from each other, right? So if
you think of it, why is this not? Yeah,
if you think of these two shapes, they
are they are not very different from
each other. You could sort of
approximate one with the other. So even
if I change to 21 parameters, I adjusted
one of these parameters 20 or 21
parameters. I adjusted it ever so
slightly um you're out of the out of
business, right? In some sense because
what you cannot uh sort of apply your
neural network which is a 20dimensional
input to a 30dimensional input. So this
imposes this parameterization.
It imposes a straight jacket on you. It
can be only useful in some very very
limited settings but it has no
generalizability whatsoever because even
if the shapes are close to each other
the parametric description doesn't make
them close to each other. Okay. So this
is sort of the the main challenge with
this uh sort of cheating. I told you
this because this is essentially a
cheating technique because okay you say
uh oh who cares about infinite
dimensional problems. I can reduce them
using suitable parameterizations to
finite dimensional problems. But then
the point is that you never are content
with that right because it does not
generalize and this is going to be a big
challenge. So whatever we do we cannot
avoid working with genuine operator
learning which is working with infinite
dimensional objects. So is that is that
more clear now? So we will not use
parameterization except perhaps to
define my data distributions. This can
happen right? I can I can define my data
distributions in terms of parameters but
the inputs that I'll give to my neural
networks will always be infinite
dimensional or always be given in terms
of functions. So this will be my sort of
learning paradigm. So I just wanted to
mention because this is used in
literature including by us and this is
how it started that okay instead of
working with an infinite dimensional
object which is intrinsically difficult
why don't we just reduce it to a fixed
set of parameters and then work with it
then you cannot generalize. Okay. So
this is uh this is a curse of this
particular or let's say the limit of
this particular breakpoint of this
particular approach. So what do we do?
So back to genuine operator learning
which is my inputs
and outputs are functions. Both of them
are functions.
So I have to either
reduce the problem to finite dimensions
not through parameterization because
that clearly doesn't work but I have to
do it either through
finite dimensional reductions or
infinite dimensional extensions. And
actually we will see both approaches. uh
one today and the one in the next
lecture and then we'll see that at the
end of the day you have to somehow
reconcile harmonize these two different
approaches. So let me just uh start with
the first one the sort of fairly naive
one and one can one can always do this
and I call this as discretized and learn
remember that uh essentially what I have
is and just for simplicity I've taken a
problem where the input and output
spaces are the same need not be the same
but in this particular case it's the
same so what you're looking at is the
solution of the Navia Stokes equation in
2D so Navia Stokes so this is UT + U
do.grad U equal to new plus gradient of
P = to new llian of U divergence of U
equals Z and U at X0. So this velocity
field is A of X. So the solution
operator is simply mapping A to U. Okay,
in this case it's probably mapping the
voticity but that that's a detail.
Anyway, so this is the the setting that
you are in. So and your domain D is
given by the unit square. It's a fairly
simple setting, right? So my G is a
mapping from some function space X to X.
Okay, X to X. So you you you you cannot
directly apply neural networks. But what
we can do is that we can discretise.
Okay, this is what after all numerical
methods also solve this problem, right?
Because in numerical methods you're
trying to sort of approximate the
solution operator which is an
intrinsically infinite dimensional
problem but the way you do it is uh
through finite dimensions through
discretizations. So what do I mean by
discretization? Roughly speaking what it
means is that I introduce uh space here
let's say Rn
and I project the space down. So I take
some e to finite dimensions. Okay. So I
take my infinite dimensional space and I
reduce it to finite dimensions. I could
have done it using parameters but this
is not done using parameters. It's done
using discretizations. What's the
difference? The difference is that uh
then there is a natural idea by which as
n increases as the number of
discretization points increase you start
hitting the function space. Okay. So
what what is it that we do here? So
there are many many different ways of
doing it. All numerical methods have
this right. So you can take finite
elements then this is in terms of basis
functions. Finite volume is also in
terms of basis functions. Spectral is
also in terms of basis functions. Finite
difference method on the other hand the
simplest one is just on the basis of
pointwise sampling. So what do I do? I
take my function input right? So this is
my function input. This is the color
map. But I say that instead of
interpreting it or instead of realizing
it on the entire domain, what I do is
that I realize it on a fixed set of
points. So in this particular case as
you can see I think I have taken 16
points in each direction. So there's a
total of 256 points. Of course 256 is
just for illustration right. So in
general so I take a fixed uh mess size
right delta and I say that I take
uniformly distributed grid of points uh
and instead of looking at the function
at every point I'm going to look at the
function only at these uh grid points.
Okay so this is a discretization and the
discretization operator. or sometimes
it's also called an encoding that's why
I use uh e
um this is just this mapping which takes
the function at all locations and
samples it at a few locations or a large
number of locations and the idea is that
uh take any um essentially as n goes to
infinity so it should be en but I don't
want to overload you with notation as n
goes to infinity as you take a denser
and denser grid or latis of points
you get the function approximated
better. Something that you cannot do
necessarily only with a fixed number of
parameters. Here the number of
parameters or the number of basis
functions grows and hence you can
approximate this. So you do this and you
can do the same at the other level.
Right? So you take another Rn
at the output and the inverse of this is
what is called a reconstruction or a
decoding R which is here. So this is an
interpolation. So given a set of points
you want to get back the function right.
So this is uh in numerical analysis this
is typically interpolation you just
interpolate by using peacewise constants
peacewise linears peacewise quadratics
whatever there are different kinds of
interpolations lrange interpolence or fa
interpolence there are all kinds of
interpolence and you can use that. So
you can go from infinite dimension to
finite dimensions and from finite
dimension you can go back to infinite
dimensions and in between uh you have a
mapping which is from finite dimensions
to finite dimensions which I called as
Lar in this particular case I don't know
there's some notational or G star I
don't even know G star is the overall
operator I see okay so I called this as
Lar so what do I do in this case uh this
approach it's a very naive approach in
some sense is that given a function
input you sample at a finite number of
points. So input is now given by 256
points a vector of 256 points or 4,96
points or whatever. Then you apply your
neural network which could be just a
multi-layer perceptron on the simplest
neural network and you get the solution
at the same number of points for
instance 256 to 256 and once you have
256 points you can extend it by
interpolation at any point. Okay, so
this is sort of the mapping. You
discretise, you apply a processor, an
MLP in this case, and then you
reconstruct using an interpolator. Okay,
is this clear? So this is also operator
learning because at the end of the day
I'm learning the operator. So given any
function input, first I apply the
encoding which is my discretization. I
just look at it at a set of points. Then
I do a finite dimensional neural network
and then to go back to infinite
dimensions I use this reconstruction
operator. So instead of going directly
from here to here as I should have I
first discretize then process using a
neural network and then interpolate and
I'm just repeating that process again
and again and again. So my infinite
dimensional problem is reduced to a
finite dimensional problem. Is this
clear?
Are there any questions about this?
And now you already see that this was
just the simplest example of pointwise
sampling. I could have just uh expressed
everything in a finite element basis and
then taken the finite element basis
functions and done the same. Right? So
this this would have been another
possibility. Good uh question from
Marco. What is Marco asking? Discretise
than learn approach uses pointwise
discretization followed by MLP to
approximate the operator.
uh could we use instead a convolutional
layer? Yeah, this comes later, Marco.
You'll see in a second. So, his question
sort of preempted my criticism. I'm just
asking on this particular slide where we
do the sort of pointwise sampling and
then we do some processing using
neuronet networks and we go back. Is
that is that clear? That's a very very
sort of a straightforward construction,
right? And then what is the learning
then? The learning is now at the level
this these are not in principle. This
could also be learnable means no one
stops us. But in in in practice we don't
do that. We we sort of take this to be a
fixed object. We take this to be a fixed
object. Interpolation sampling and then
this is my learnable object and what is
being learned. So these are neural
networks as always. So now all that I do
is okay. So Oliver if the resolution
yeah this again you guys are preempting
me.
So I I will I will come to those points
uh in a second. So let's just focus on
what is intrinsically being learned
here. So what is being learned now is
just this finite dimensional map because
um when you have the data pairs you can
do the same. Remember that we have been
given some AI and G of AI right so this
is given to us. So for these data pairs
you do the same you you do the finite
dimensional projection on both sides and
then you get a mapping which uh which
takes you from the input to the output
and this is what you're going to match
because all that you do is that your Lar
is going to approximate the L L is for
the exact uh for the ground truth
for the ground truth and this is what I
wrote down here right so G your ground
truth is given in terms the same
operators and its projection is called
L. So now you're going to match L with
respect to Lar. Okay, very very simple
process, very very easy to code. Uh
nothing. You take a function, you you
take your training training data set. Uh
you take a function, you sample it uh
you take the output, sample it, use a
neural network to match them. And at the
time of inference, what do you do? You
take the uh input function, you sample
them on the fixed set of points, apply
your train neural network, you get the
output at the fixed set of points,
interpolate to get any other point.
Right? So this is this is a
straightforward uh straightforward thing
but the mapping now is a mapping between
the discretization space to the
discretization space. That's what your
neural network maps. Now as many of your
colleagues already anticipated and asked
me there are some serious caveats with
this. Uh there are actually three but
all of them are killers in some sense
right they they tell you that you cannot
uh sort of do anything about this. So
the first thing is almost immediately
you will have the issue of very large
model sizes. Okay. So if you discretize
on a 16x6 grid you can imagine that
there's a very coarse discretization
right. So for a fine discretization you
have to go to large grids. So even if
you take uh 64 squared grid okay this is
nothing mean this is a very standard
grid then the number of points at which
you're discretizing in 2D is going to be
4,96
and in 3D it's like uh 200,000 right so
in 3D it increases by a very very big
factor uh by a factor of 8 so it's it's
it's it's it's a very large it's going
to be a very very large number so now
just imagine that your input is 4,000
points your output is going to be 4,000
points. So roughly let's uh approximate
it to uh 10 ^ 4 10 ^ 4 on the output
side. So the matrices that go in if you
use an MLP remember that the matrices
takes your inputs vector and put it into
output vector this will be 10 ^ 8 100
million 10 to 100 million just for one
layer. Okay, just for one layer you will
get this. And when you increase the
discretization to 128 squared, right? So
instead of uh 64 squared, you go to 128
squared. This increases by another
factor of 10. And then uh this is just
uh this is this is just too much right
you cannot deal with such uh such large
points. In fact in images also you have
the same problem. You can't take u MLPS
at the level of individual pixels
because this will be even for shallow
MLP single layer MLP just imagine using
100 million model to solve such a simple
problem doesn't make any sense right so
this is a this is a huge caveat another
caveat is that these points are not
independent of each other right the
these this information there is some
structure there is some spatial
structure that's why someone suggested
convolutions and you'll see in the
second uh in second slide that there is
there is going to be an issue with
convolutions but so this is uh the
spatial structure is not incorporated.
We are treating these uh closely related
points as uh being very different from
each other which is which is far from
the case. But the most important problem
is that uh and this is I think Oliver
someone touched upon this is that we
cannot evaluate on a different
resolution. Now let me try to explain
this concept because this is uh at core
of what we are going to talk about.
So what does it mean now? So what are we
what have we done? So let's uh just
focus on 1D so that I can draw more
easily. So you are in 1D. So let's
imagine that you have uh 0 to 1 and 0 to
1.
And let me try to explain this in some
some detail even though that will mean
that I don't finish what I plan to do.
So let's say that we have been given
some input
and we get some output which could be
more oscilly.
So this is going to be your input
input
and output
and in between them is your operator G.
Right? So this is typically my input and
output. Now what did I do in this
discretization process is that I said
okay all that I do is I take a fixed
number of points just for simplicity
let's take four points okay so this one
two three points and I do this
discretization on the same four points
one two three points
okay so now I have input and output and
essentially what I do is uh if I neglect
my so I have divided the interval into
four four pieces just for simplicity. So
let's say that I even take my boundary
points into account. This this this is
fine. So essentially what I'm doing in
this case is I'm learning a map from R5
to R5.
Right? So this is my MLP.
So now for each of my inputs all that I
do is I take my red function. I sample
it at the blue points. I apply my MLP. I
will read out its value at these blue
points and then I interpolate. Okay,
very coarse in this case just for
illustration but it does the job. But
remember that my functions are
functions. These are not values at five
points. What if I change my resolution?
So what do I mean by that? What I mean
by that is let's take a different
resolution. Let's see how I do it.
I can try to see if I can squeeze in.
Yeah. So, this is again 0 to one. Then 0
to one
here.
And I have the same sort of function
input.
Just a bad drawing. Okay. And the same
output
something like this. Right. So this is
my input and output. But who tells me
that I have to discretise at five
points, right? This is a function. I can
discretize it at any number of points.
And so let us refine now. So instead of
coarsening, let us refine. So earlier we
had this points, right? So we had these
points.
But now, okay, something like this. But
now I take a few more points. I take a
point here. Take a point here. Take a
point here. Take a point here. and do
the same thing at the output level. My
function doesn't change, right? I have
more number of points now. So I have a
better description uh of the function.
So now my input and output map suddenly
changes. It becomes from R9 to R9,
right? But uh phenito we we can't do
anything right because uh so all that
I'm doing is I'm asking if I change my
resolution to a better resolution. If I
have more data for instance or if I want
a more finer uh description of the
problem my function input doesn't change
at all. It is exactly the same function
input but now I am using different sets
of points to understand uh to interpret
it to realize it. then uh this extra
information is going to be totally lost
right because then uh I I don't have a
way to use this extra information and I
cannot generalize I cannot change my
resolution right this uh resolution
cannot be changed so you are left with
giving these points I will just uh
choose the old points okay or if I
change these points uh then I have to
interpolate and I have to find the value
at the old points and so on so this is
not very and if I coen my resolution
instead of giving
eight points. Let's say that I'm just
given the value at this point. What can
happen, right? This point and this point
just three points. Then what do I do? Uh
nothing. I can do nothing because uh
then again I have to sort of interpolate
the function and find it. But uh I have
this is too much of a straight jacket.
You see I can change the resolution but
it's not automatic. It's not in the
architecture itself. I always have to
resize my input and then put it into a
five-dimensional
MLP and this is not genuine operator
learning because in that case what
happens is that I'm just learning not
the function itself but I'm learning I
can't even evaluate it at a different
set of points right so this is what I
think I wrote down that it is not even
possible to evaluate unless until you do
these tricks like interpolation or
sampling it's not even possible to
evaluate on um Okay, why is this not
possible to evaluate on a different
resolution? And this is sort of uh is
not genuine operator learning. Genuine
operator learning is that okay I'm um
because I have to use a computer there
is no way I can I can work with infinite
dimensional quantities but in principle
I shouldn't be seeing or my architecture
my model shouldn't even be seeing these
uh these points. It should purely work
at the level of functions. It should go
from here to here, here to here. So if I
change the resolution, it shouldn't
really matter. But at the moment with
this particular very simplistic
approach, even this is not possible.
Right? So you have lots and lots of
caveats. But the first and the third one
are the more important ones that you
cannot have uh model sizes and you
cannot evaluate at different
resolutions. So this is not genuine
operator learning and we are going to
use I think one of your colleagues
already suggested that we are going to
solve these problems one by one in the
route or in the road towards uh genuine
operator learning but that is I think I
have 5 minutes left there's only so much
I can do so I think it's a good time to
stop uh next time I will yeah there's a
question from Mateo Mateo why don't you
ask your question
Hello.
>> Sorry, it was just a mistake.
>> Okay, no worries. If someone has a
question, you can always ask over the
chat, right? So, I think uh Oliver's
question was answered by this uh
resolution thing. So, I think we have to
stop here uh and take a 5 minute early
break. Uh so, my point is in the next
lecture what we'll try to do is we'll go
towards genuine operator learning. But
you see in one lecture we took quite a
bit of a leap. We went from sort of
pointwise understanding through pins to
this more operator centric systemic
understanding through operators but then
we create a lot of problems because we
have to deal with infinite dimensional
objects and that's hard nut to crack and
but this is what we will do in the next
lecture in the lecture afterwards you
will see that this there is a there are
solutions to this very difficult
problem. Okay. So with this uh I stop
and thank you very much for your
attention.